this holiday weekend community pools in
the valley going to be opening up jeremy
j ford over at durango hills ymca water
park and how staff are prepping and
getting ready for the summer
i feel ready at most at all times
actually samari mann is a lead lifeguard
at the heinrich ymca she tells me she's
been training hard in preparation for
the opening of the water park very
extensive training going on right now
we're training our leads to for safety
and for customer service her goal as a
lead is to make sure that everyone who
visits the property stays safe at all of
our pools we have
overlapping stands so you'll always have
a lifeguard looking at your child in
some type of way ymca executive director
brianna barber says safety also includes
when children are out of the water so we
do a safety break at the top of every
hour at each of our water parks and this
is to ensure that patrons get out of the
pool they have an opportunity to have a
sip of water have a snack reapply
sunblock as well along with making sure
their water park can be safely used by
all in regards to the aquatics
experience we believe every child should
learn how to swim jeremy j ford live
local now